[Musique]
bienvenue à creissels den bonjour nous
sommes nouveaux vlad et barnabas t pêche
[Musique]
dans un lieu magique crise felden abri
depuis plus de sept cents ans l'école de
magie la plus réputée de toute la
planète
entouré d'une forêt obscure vous pouvez
marcher pendant des jours vous sortirez
toujours par l'endroit où vous êtes
entré des êtres enchanté votre septième
année est une année match c'est l'année
où vous allez accueillir votre héritage
familial
et trois amis extraordinaire je
m'appelle vlad un vampire qui supportent
pas le sens je suis fait une fée qui a
peur de voler moi c'est wolf un loup
garou tient une allergie aux poils vont
devoir accomplir leur plus grande
mission après de nombreuses luttes
viendra le temps où le mât contrats pour
des prunes à salles d'abord puis 3 unis
pour dompter leurs faiblesses sauver le
monde magique
comment fait pour traverser
puis le fragment de sang
[Musique]
là ces enfants tranquilles
tagro c'est pas le bon seront pas de
panique le magic kids est un peu plus
haut encore j'en ai bien peur way